thing like this because i remember
that
during my undergrad i was so excited to
go to grad school i started my master's
i was working in a lab the techniques
were great the science was fantastic but
i also felt like there's this emerging
field of metagenomics
that i barely learned about when i was
undergrad and now as a master's student
there was other people doing it and i
had no idea what it was about
so after i finished my masters i made
sure to switch fields to get into this
field because i knew it was the future
so here metaomix is still the future and
still thriving but we're building upon
it
okay so i love the introduction we
talked about a metagenome and what that
is
so to start off just as a recap a
metagenome is just taking nucleic acid
dna specifically from a sample and
you're reconstructing all of the genomes
in that sample so this is everything
that's in that sample
so this first figure i wanted to show
you
is from simon rue's 2019 paper
where he's showing
the rise of viral populations so let me
orient your view here so on the y-axis
we have number of sequences and on the
x-axis we have a timeline so the very
first meta
was about 2005 and this would be done in
joe banfield's lab with gene tyson's
lead author where they were looking at a
metagenome from an acid mine drainage
and then arguably the first virum was
about
2007 but our techniques were very
different than they are now
and the main thing you want to take away
from here
is that in green and blue we have all of
everything we know about viruses from
isolates and blue meaning we have all of
them and then in green meaning these are
complete genomes so even in isolates we
always get complete genomes and then
with the advent of metagenomics the
discovery of viruses has exploded and
you'll see acronyms out there like u v i
or u v i g s and data these just mean
viral populations so when we talk about
viruses there's so many nuances in their
genomes like you're probably imagining
with
covid going around now the stars cov2
there's all these different variants
right they can be described into
populations especially if we're trying
to understand how the community is
interacting so the way we do this is we
take similar organisms and we cluster
them based on a sequence similarity so
we'll typically use a 95 average
nucleotide similarity
and then we'll do a cut off for the
genome length and we typically are
looking at double stranded dna viruses
for most metagenomic studies
so what we'll do is we'll usually do a
10kb cutoff so we'll say 95 average
nucleotide identity across a range of
the genome and the currently accepted
threshold is 85
of the contig length so we cluster these
genomes together and the longest one of
the clustering is our representative
viral population
now you can imagine we're going to miss
subtle these and differences amongst
these genomes so it's always good to
dive back in and really look for
differences between these viral genomes
especially for gene specificities
so just moving forward this is where the
field is now is that we're getting
this vast discovery of viruses from
metagenomics metagenomics is our main
tool and metagenomics is really
capturing double-stranded dna viruses
because the technology was set up for
microbial genomes which is
double-stranded dna
and from a metagenome you can get the
double-stranded dna viruses and you can
also get the microbial host information
so you're able to link them together
which is great
now a problem is we get low resolution
on viruses which is what the remainder
of my talk is going to be about
to show you how things have changed
myself and others have really been
pushing hard in soils because they've
languished so on the figure on the right
here we have the number of virus
specific meta studies and the total has
exponentially increased
and it seems that human and marine are
the ones taking off the most but we're
trying to push to get soils up there as
well and then there's so many other
fields in between that are just i didn't
bring up
okay
let's discuss the problem
we know that you get low resolution on
viruses
we get on average about less than two
percent of our assembled reads going to
viral context
and it seems like the most of these
viruses are described are viruses that
are either integrated or associated with
the most abundant host so we're
bottlenecking and obscuring our view to
only focus on these most abundant ones
proxy to their hosts
so the reason why we get such low
resolution viruses in general is just
because if you look at a soil sample
there is so much going on you're
collecting genomic information on plants
on the macrophanol we're talking about
your mites you can go to your mesophony
we talk about your nemo totes and then
you can go lower into your micro
eukaryotes your amoebas and then you
finally get lower into our microbes in
which we have to zoom in and this is
what a lot of people care about but then
if you want to know viruses you have to
zoom in even further to finally see the
viruses
so my whole phd and what my career has
been about is increasing our resolution
on viruses and again this has
application across all fields currently
we're
wanting to learn how to better detect
different viruses in the environment and
increase our threshold in which we can
detect viruses so all of these have
similar applications
i see that i have a couple comments in
the chat i'm just going to wait to the
end to answer those unless there's a
pressing issue and then please interrupt
me
i'm wondering if we can
somehow move this so it's not blocking
sorry about that
[Music]
hold on one second
okay i'm sorry oh you're not gonna be
able to see the titles but i will give
you
information on what's going on
so what i've started to do during my
postdoc and now as a staff scientist is
really to understand and increase our
focus on what we actually care about so
when you look at an environmental sample
you do want to know everything's there
everything that is there we want to know
what they're doing this is your genetic
repertoire you want to know all the
capabilities of what's going on
but we also care at each point in time
who's actually doing what
and the more we study microbes and other
organisms and how they interact the more
we understand that not everything's
active at a single time point that
actually in soils a majority of
microorganisms are inactive
they can be active they can be growing
but a lot of them also dormant or
they're just deceased and we're picking
up what's called this relic or ancient
dna from the soil environments
so to get around this we use stable
isotope probing as one way
so this is where we take an isotope and
this first example i'm going to tell you
it's going to be for
for oxygen so we have regular water
which is typically
h216o
but we can make what's called heavy
water which is
h218o not to confuse with deuterium
we're specifically using 18o
so when we add this to an environment
like soil
water is a universal substrate so
anything that's active
is going to have to use this water so it
becomes labeled with the 18o within its
dna so we can detect everything that's
active now for viruses if they're
infecting a host
then they will also get labeled so the
viruses get labeled as well
in another example
i'm going to show you how we can look at
substrate specificity so here you have
plant biomass which usually has
normal carbon which is 12c
we can grow plant biomass with under 13
co2 so it's in rich plant biomass so the
majority or all of the plant is 13c
enriched we can then look at who's
degrading that plant biomass because any
organisms that are breaking down will
become 13c and rich and so will their
viruses so this won't label all active
organisms and biological entities this
will only label the ones that are
involved in breaking down the plant
biomass so it's substrate specific
so what we typically do from this is we
incubate the sample this will be soil
for a period of time then we extract all
the dna like you would from metagenome
but then we take the dna
and we put it on a cesium chloride
density gradient and we do
ultrasonification
the dna will separate into the different
layers of cesium chloride density based
on enrichment so you'll have dormant or
ceased ones that didn't intake didn't
take up the 18o or didn't take up the
13c up higher in the lighter fractions
the ones incorporated the heavier
isotope that's more dense will be in the
denser fractions and we can physically
separate these and sequence in them
separately and compare them now there
are differences in this obviously
there's organisms that are gc rich that
can make them more dense so we end up
taking many fractions comparing those
fractions
but it's important always sequence both
the light and the heavy fractions this
allows us to get the genetic repertoire
of everything that's going on remember
we took a snapshot in time so it could
be that the metabolisms that weren't
active had just stopped right before we
added it for some reason so this is
where time series also comes in handy
but then also allows us a control to
compare it to to see differences in
growth and changes in the communities
so the first example i'm going to talk
about is with the heavy water and this
is a paper i recently published i think
came out in august of last year
and this is where we went to bonanza
creek and alaska in a zone that has
permafrost which is ground that's frozen
for two more consecutive years
now the assumption is in these northern
latitudes siberia um scandinavia
canada alaska
that over the winter organisms just
don't function
and be or it's minimum so they just
ignore a lot of the carbon that leaves
these soils and they don't want to
measure it but we've known for quite
some time that this is false so we
wanted to actually
connect microbes and viruses to carbon
cycling over winter months
so we sampled bonanza creek
and we collected the peat soils
and then we took the soil we incubated
in a jar for a half a year and for full
year and we did some of the samples with
regular water and then some with
enriched water
and then we also brought the temperature
of the vials down slowly over time to
negative 1.5 celsius and we also made
sure they're an axe anoxic with a
nitrogen headspace so this will mimic
the in-situ winter conditions
after the incubation we then did the
cesium chloride density fractions and we
secrete them separately and we
reconstructed 23 metagenomes
along with this we were collecting
headspace measurements so we can measure
co2 production over time so in the
figure at the bottom you can see in
purple from our samples that we had co2
production that occurred over the full
year incubation we also saw on our other
control which we brought down the
negative 20 that there was no production
so somewhere in between there we have
our limits of life being able to
respire
so i'm going to just do some quick
highlights but the main things i wanted
to focus is on the viruses here
so i have a heat map here on the x-axis
we found 332 viral populations
on the y-axis i have a four different
treatments we have regular water for a
half a year in rich water for a half
year and then both for a full year and i
compared them
so if we look at just the bottom part
that's our active ones so we found that
243 of our 342 populations were active
over the winter so it's incredible as
the large amount of viruses active in
the winter
we're looking at just the active ones
now we first noticed comparing a half
year to a full year that many of the
viral populations persisted so if you
look from the happier full year they're
still there so that's the first thing to
note
the second thing is that a large portion
of them actually increase their
abundance over time so it's not like
they were active and then they just sat
there they continue to infect or
multiply in the host over the rest of
the year
and some theories on what could have
happened is that these could have been
temporary viruses that were integrated
in the host and as the host
doubled the virus also doubled it could
be that they burst out of their hosts
and made virions and the virons
persisted in the environment and we do
get a little bit of this in our
metagenomes but it's not targeted like a
virum so we don't get a lot of virions
it also could be that these viruses and
maybe the hosts died and exploded and
because these are p-lens soils and their
soils the
dna is protected so it could be that
they just remained as relic dna in the
environment
i also want to highlight to the left you
can see we had viruses eight viral
populations that were present at a half
year and were no longer present after a
full year so we're seeing this dynamic
community in which populations are
leaving and populations are coming into
play
then that brings us into the 151 new
populations that just occurred from a
half year to a full year and not discuss
too much more about it but if you look
at the host it seems like the viruses
are mimicking the host that when the
host populations are changing the viral
populations are changing too following
the kill the winter hypothesis
to talk about the host a little bit we
had this huge diversity
where we attend bacteriophyla
in these subfreezing anoxic soils which
is incredible in itself
but we also saw that seven of the ten
phyla were active so we had bacteria
that are active over winter so that
means they're doing something
and if you were to take a traditional
metagenome you would have sampled all of
these and you would have seen that there
was 10 bacterophylla you would have also
specifically focused on actinobacteria
because if you look at general reed
information and coverage the
actinobacteria dominated the signal
but this just occluded the actual truth
of what was going on
when we actually looked at the active
organisms
we saw that latino bacteria were not
even that active that the majority of
them were actually firm acutes and
bacteria deities so we would have missed
this signal had we not done the stable
isotope probing metagenome
of those seven only four actually had
viruses in which we detected were
infecting the host and then they changed
throughout the year as well so i wanted
to highlight that we had the the patsy
bacteria these are incredible because
these are ultra small bacteria part of
the canon phylum radiation which is
newly discovered so these organisms are
interesting because they don't really
have a free living system they have to
connect with other hosts so they
typically can connect with bacteria dds
or actinobacteria so there may be some
syntrophic relationship with viruses
infecting multiple hosts
we also found our proteobacteria
specifically these vampiric bacteria
which these are
bacteria that have to attach to other
bacteria and feed on them to survive and
we found viruses infecting these
bacteria
and then again as i said before the
firmicutes and the bacteritis were the
most abundant phyla and these are the
ones the viruses switched to infect
throughout the year
okay so just to sum it up i'm happy to
talk more if people want to know more
about the paper but some key takeaways
there's major differences between the
active and the unlabeled communities so
there is promise and trying to decrease
our complexity and look at the active
portion only
we found only a few bacterial
populations are active but we found a
ton of viral populations that were
active
when we looked more to the host
abilities they had the ability for
fermentation and to also break down
carbon and they produce co2 throughout
the whole sample so this is important
because this showed and links bacteria
to producing carbon dioxide over winter
processes so we need to be thinking
about co2 loss over the winter
especially because there's some studies
out there that suggest that co2 loss
over the winter is actually more than
the entire plant uptake during the
growing season
so we had one third of our viruses were
linked to active hosts we may be able to
increase this if we were able to do a
viral targeted metagenome also known as
a virum
we also found that viruses included
these key genes to modulate the host
metabolism so these are known as
auxiliary metabolic genes these are
genes that are outside the viruses
normal repertoire to infect the host and
sometimes can bring genetic novelty to
the host or can modulate the host
metabolism in this case they help the
host with carbon degradation and also
scavenging nutrients from the
environment probably aiding in survival
and then i think it's important to note
that the viral community did shift from
who they infected from a half year to a
full year which was supporting the kill
the winner hypothesis showing that the
viral communities do shift to who the
most abundant host is
okay so for our next experiment this is
going into our 13c enriched plant
biomass we're now shifting gears getting
out of that frigid cold arctic
environment we're now in the lush
tropical rainforest in puerto rico the
lukiyo experimental forest
so this is the puerto rico's part of the
united states and this is the only
tropical rainforest that is part of the
united states so we sampled there and
what's important to know about these
environments is they have tropical
storms
so it's a it's a common occurrence for
there to be heavy rainfalls and dry
periods so these soils undergo heavy
redox conditions where it can be anoxic
and then oxic and we're wondering how
this affects the fate of the carbon and
how what tools have the and traits have
the microbes picked up to survive and
what are the viruses doing
so this experiment was designed by
ashley campbell and managed by our group
leader jennifer pettrich the far right
and then i had jeff kimbrough and steve
blazewicz that helped me as well
and they designed this experiment where
they took soil samples
and for 44 days they incubated them
under four different treatments
and they added the 20 grams of the soil
with the plant biomass and i just want
to remind you that this is not labeling
all active organisms so we're
specifically looking at ones involved in
degrading or breaking down the plant
biomass
so the treatment setup was it was either
completely oxidic with air being flushed
in it was frequency between oxygen
anoxic at a high amount or a low amount
or we had ones that were completely
anoxic with an n2 headspace
from this we are able to take 95
metagenomes so this is huge we had
terabytes of data
now we wanted to really compare and ask
the question
when we do the sip fractionation and
we're looking at the active ones are we
actually decreasing the complexity
enough to actually get increased
resolution so we took 85 sip fraction
and metagenomes this is where you
extract the dna and then we do the
different fractions to see which ones
are heavy and light and then we compare
them and then we have 10 bulk soil meta
genomes this is just we took some soil
we extracted dna and we sequenced it so
this is your traditional medicine and we
wanted to compare them
okay i have a heat map here again and
let me orient you to how it works on the
x-axis we have our viral populations you
can see already we had double the amount
of viral populations compared to our
arctic samples
now for the color scheme
an orange means whitening is not present
orange means low abundance green means
high abundance and then the y axis i
have it separated from in black our bulk
meta genomes with our different
treatments
in blue we have our no addition this is
just plant biomass so it's our control
and then in red at the bottom we have
our 13 c enriched plant biomass that we
added to compare and you can see we see
viruses in all the samples and there are
some changes
so now we're going to dig more into
those active ones the ones involved in
carbon degradation
so looking at this the first thing you
should notice is that there's more viral
populations in the oxic samples so we've
known for quite some time that oxygen
really affects viruses and it makes
sense when a virus is infecting a host
if it's lytic it wants to take over the
host and make progeny viruses
this is oxygenic metabolism that you
need so we see about a third of our
populations were here
and then you see some changes when we
have redox conditions
but what is super cool
sorry so we have about a third that are
in all the conditions
um but what's important to note
is that in the oxic ones we have 27
percent more viral populations so you
think oxygen is important but then if
you look at the anoxic one while we have
less diversity
the virus the viral populations that are
there
are the most abundant
so here i'm thinking we have some
viruses
that you know they probably don't have a
broad host range they probably don't
have these large genomes these are
specialists they've changed the way they
infect
to change the host metabolism where now
we have this anoxic metabolism
completely different pathways and
viruses evolved to work with this and we
don't have these oxygenated viruses here
so this is a niche spot
just for these viruses and this story is
not published yet so i'm still actively
looking into
what these viruses are doing because
this has important implications for us
right we have parts of our body that are
oxygenated and we have parts of our body
that's anoxic so our microbiome
including our viruses are going to
change in those different redox
conditions
okay so then just to highlight the host
real quick we had massive diversity i
mean these are tropical rainforest soils
this is something you would expect we
had 20 phyla of bacteria detected
and in here in this figure f here i have
a lovial chart
on the first column we have all of our
viruses in the middle i was trying to
get an understanding of connecting
viruses to the host amongst the
different redox treatments and then the
far right column we have a different
phyla of bacterium the main takeaway i
want you to get from here is that we
have huge diversity and if you kind of
follow the green which are the viruses
that were 13c labeled they don't go to
all phyla they specifically span i think
it's eight phyla
and we wanted to look more into those
specific phyla because these are the
ones that are really controlling the
fate of the carbon in this environment
so the next thing we want to do is be is
wanted to look well what are the host
capabilities because the virus can only
do so much for the hosts infecting right
you're driving a car now if your friend
has a mercedes and you have a little
scooter you're both driving a vehicle
but they have more influence they have
the capacity to go faster than you and
further than you because of what they're
in so this is like the virus in fact in
the host right it's limited based on the
capacity of the host
so we did is we wanted to look for the
various ways they could break down
carbon substrates
so i'm going to show you all of them but
i wanted to zoom in on one to orient you
and get you thinking about this we have
the phylum actinobacteria
on the y-axis we have the number of
genes within their genome and on the
x-axis it's the number of genes
within that substrate class so the first
one's cellulose so every circle there is
a bacterial genome that's an
actinobacteria and the entire up of it
has more genes to break down cellulose
okay
so higher counts means higher capacity
to break down plant biomass
higher counts across the whole field
means a high diversity breakdown a range
of substrates
okay
so what we realized is that we took all
20 phyla and we looked at which ones the
viruses were infecting the viruses were
infecting the key carbon degraders so
the ones
with the largest amount of genes
involved in the highest diversity for
plant degradation so the viruses are
actually caring a lot about the carbon
and influencing the fate of this carbon
so this is just them doing it via
infecting the host by infecting the host
they can increase the host metabolism to
make more viruses they can light
somewhat dormant i don't like to use the
word dormant because while they're
integrated they're just not there they
are still doing
um
maintenance they're also encoding
different toxin genes to help the host
and protect the host from other
infection and keep it happy so there's a
lot viruses are doing
but if we look more at other ways the
viruses could be influenced metabolism
we start thinking about the different
ways in which they can control carbon
cycling so like i said before they lyse
the host this is releasing nutrients
into the environment that's a top down
control
if we
are also
expressing amgs this is augmenting the
host metabolism
we can make their metabolism more
efficient and make them out-compete
other populations as well
so we looked for these amgs and we found
a whole slew of amgs within our viral
populations connected to our
hosts we think about this more because
i'm not done with this paper yet but
we're looking what is the fate of this
carbon okay so first idea is this kill
the one hypothesis right the viruses are
shifting who they're infecting
we it's hard to see that here because
it's a 44 day incubation and there's not
really a time comparison so we really
can't see this but we know that viruses
are infecting the most abundant posts
that are involved in plant biomass
degradation so we do see that so this
could be maintaining the microbial
diversity and they're also killing all
these hosts creating diverse substrates
feeding other organisms
another thing you could be doing is the
viral shine where they're killing the
host
necromance microbial necromancer all the
nutrients is becoming available but then
it's sticking and in these soils we have
phosphorus limitation and then we have
all these different pore sizes that
microbes can't fit in so maybe that the
viruses are killing these hosts these
nutrients are going in these small pore
sizes and it's inaccessible
to other microbes so it just keeps
carbon in the soil
and then this leads us to atonement so
by keeping that carbon in the soil it's
inaccessible it can persist for long
periods of time until maybe we till the
soil making it available for other
organisms there's a flood or there's a
storm that moves the soil or they're
small organisms like ultra small
bacteria that can make their way within
these pores and break down this carbon
okay
now that is stuff that i was currently
working on
about a year ago i got a grant so this
is what's called my ldrd and this is to
really push the field the government
gave me a grant
for something that's called high risk
high reward you're doing science that
has a high chance to fail
but if you were able to complete it
then it would be very valuable to the
community
so what i wanted to do was other ways we
could tackle increasing our detection of
microbes and viruses and getting better
resolution and again going at soils is a
great way because there's all of this
going on so how do we tease it apart and
really figure out what's going on
well we set up doing metagenomes
incubated with heavy water so i did over
a time series i took some soil i did
four different treatments over a time
series so the new component says i'm
adding time to really see how viruses
and microbes are changing
and how their host interactions are
changing but we're also adding in our
heavy water to look at the active
community over time but i also added in
a phosphorus addition because i wanted
to see you know these these soils are
limited in phosphorus so if we're adding
phosphorus is this going to spur
infection
so that was the first part but that
alone doesn't just help us with our
detection so at the same time with these
soils i also took a viral which is a
viral targeted medicine and this is
actually what i spent my whole phd
optimizing this is where you can take a
sample for here i'll take a soil sample
and you add a resuspension buffer to
help deserve the viruses from the
environment
you physically separate them and you run
through a filter so now you're looking
at the viral size fraction
and then you want to purify it so that
way it's not sticking anything and then
you extract the dna and concentrate
so now we're looking at not just the
double stranded dna that you get from a
metagenome but we've also
optimized it so we can get single and
double-stranded dna viruses from the
soil
and i've been recently working with jgis
with emily and simon roux here
in which we're trying to get stable
isopropyl virus the first of their kind
so this would be looking at active
viruses but in the virion stage in the
environment so there's no incorporations
host
okay so the benefits here is we get
increased resolution on viruses and
we've shown this with previous work
you can also get increased resolution on
the ultra small microbes because they
make it to the fraction but we lose our
host information so it's good to have it
paired with the meta genome which is
what i've done
but we're still not done i wanted to
increase resolution of all of our
viruses correct
then we also added a meta transcriptome
rna viruses are super important
and a lot of mammals especially humans
and gorillas we see it seems to dominate
the literature like we only care about
rna viruses
but it's funny because for ecology when
you go into environmental systems like
soil or water they seem to be missed out
on we are only looking at
double-stranded dna viruses but there
have been recent studies looking at rna
viruses so i wanted to be able to
capture these also from this same sample
so we're gonna get double-stranded
single-stranded dna viruses and also rna
viruses
so this will capture all of our rna
viruses we'll also be able to get gene
expression for a host and for our dna
viruses which would be great we're still
limited to the point where we have to
remove trna and rrna because they
swamped the signal so we do lose a
little bit of information there
finally something that i newly invented
and i'm working on is what i call the
edna metagenome there's been recent
studies that i think the first paper
that really pushed it into the eyes of
people was paul carinis carini's 2016
paper
where he sampled some soils
and they found a lot of edna and that by
looking at the edna you're actually
seeing variances in the abundances of
your host so you need to be careful of
how much of the e dna is actually just
relic dna lying around
and just to clarify relic dna ancient
dna edna which can be exogenous dna or
environmental dna it's all very similar
just dna that's free in the environment
that we're trying to understand
now i was working with this because
there's recent papers from wastewater
treatment facilities and aquatic
environments
showing that if you look at the e-dna
you can actually get increased detection
of viruses so i'm wanting to monitor the
viruses and get this increased detection
so we sampled edna from our soils to
reconstructed that
so just from this one soil sample over
this time series with these four
different treatments
we have a ton of sipmetic genomes we
have bulk metagenomes sip firearms bulk
firearms bulk metagenomes and e-dna ohms
that we're comparing and this is the
work that i'm actively doing right now
so i think in six months two years start
seeing some results coming from this and
looking at the whole soil virus sphere
or the sample and this is really looking
at the the viral ohm really of the soil
like all the different components of the
virus sphere
okay
so i'm gonna wrap up now but i wanted to
also talk about another component to
make sure that we're not missing out on
it
one of the issues with metagenomics
is that everyone everyone thinks
metaomic studies which is metagenomics
miniature experimental metaproteomics
and so on and meta metabolics
that we're thinking we can just do it
and we're done
we need to make sure that we're taking
controls and trying to be quantitative
by adding in stable isotope probing we
can start looking activity you can also
add in bond cat which is bio-orthogonal
non-canonical amino acid tagging and
this can also get at activity
but another way too is we can try to use
microscopy to make sure we're
quantitative so what we're doing here is
we're taking our soil samples in which
we've taken these metagenomes and so on
and we're separating them and we're
trying to count the number of viral
particles now epifluorescence microscopy
doesn't do so well especially in soils
so we'll use transmission electron
microscopy but we've also taken a step
further and we've paired it with
nanosims which is nanoscale secondary
ion mass spectroscopy
and the way this works is you take a
sample
you sputter it with a cesium beam
it destroys a sample but every time it
hits a sample it charges the sample and
the computer can read it and can
reconstruct an image
so these figures you see have these
micrographs that are gray those are tem
images that we can see viruses and you
can see in the top right here we have
m13 phase which is a filamentous phage
that infects um
e coli
we also have down here we've been
working with lambda phage which is an
iconic um
sipoviridae shape and that also can
infect bacteria
now you can look over to the far right
we can start to do nano sims and
nanotubes is great because it allows us
to not only quantitatively count the
viral particles but we can also see
the elemental composition
we can see if it's 13 c and rh versus 12
c rich we can see if there's carbon
there we can see if there's oxygen so we
can look at where the enrichment is
going we can also know what nutrients
they're taking from the host and what
nutrients they're putting in their
environment so this is something we're
actively working on as well
to try to quantify phage from the
environment but also better understand
their nutrients that they hold on to
okay so hopefully that wasn't too much
i'm sorry i was trying not to go too
fast but i want to leave time for
questions
i want to acknowledge everyone i worked
with i love universities
i never thought i'd work in a national
lab since coming to a national lab i see
so many benefits
how you can really hone in on your
science and i can really connect with
universities so i can still teach if i
want to and give back to the community
so i really want to acknowledge jennifer
pettridge and steve blasiowicz they've
been excellent mentors and helped me
convert to a staff scientist we have
tons of funding we have ldrd for high
risk and rewards research to steve that
i came in on i currently have mine as
well
we were funded by other organizations
for some of the studies we also have our
large
sfa which is a science focus area that's
ongoing for the next couple years where
we're really trying to understand
how precipitation affects microbial
populations in soils specifically in
california we will have absolutely no
rainfall really from about may
to october sometimes
and so we have all of these organisms
including the grass that just go dormant
and then from about november
to april may we'll start to get rainfall
and these organisms will come alive and
this really controls the carbon output
from the car from the sorry the carbon
output from the soil so we're trying to
understand how moisture really dictates
these communities and their traits
and then lastly i want to do a land
acknowledgement we're only here because
the people that took care of this land
so i'm super appreciative of being able
to sample these lands and work on these
lands and have the privilege of
continuing to do my science
um so with that i'll just take any
questions now
thank you so much dr gary it was so
amazing and so intriguing to learn about
these hidden
communities of viruses and bacteria
and really their properties of them
being dormant and active and
shifting and
processing the carbon affecting the
metabolic
metabolisms of the host is so much
fascinating thank you so much for
sharing this amazing presentation and
research
discussion with us
well we have a lot of questions in the
chat
from
iman so
they are very interested and very
intrigued so maybe i'll put some of the
questions for you which
would seem to be most interesting so
this is something which i think many of
us heard for the first time that is the
e-dna so
there's a
question in the chat that where do you
find the e-dna where is it or is it
similar to the multivesicular nucleic
acid in liquid biopsy that we find in
human beings so could you explain e-dna
once again
yeah so it's an all-encompassing term
and it has so many different ways in
which it's said and they try to mean
different things so at its base
e dna is either extra
extra polymetric dna
exogenous dna environmental dna this is
dna that was in a biological entity so i
say that because viruses are not
considered organisms so whether it's
from a virus or a microbe an amoeba a
human
it's in the environment
it doesn't matter if it's put there on
purpose or by accident so we know that
microbes can exude dna and they can use
it to help build biofilms
the e-dna is a huge part of biofilms we
also know when a microbe dies its dna
goes into the environment it's sticky it
sticks places
now in some environments it can be
degraded rather quickly
if it lands on metal
sometimes in the ocean there's not a lot
of e-dna depending where you are but in
soils it gets into the various pores and
it attaches to the colloids in different
ways whether it's silt clay or sand
it can hide the dna and it can help
preserve it so p-lens are so popular
because these are found in northern
latitudes generally but this is where
microbial degradation is limited usually
because of temperature so you get this
buildup of plant biomass sometimes
animal biomass as well if anyone's from
the northern hemis northern latitude you
you see this it's kind of cushy to walk
across
and we call it peat because there's not
that much soil in it even though it is
soil it's mainly this plant and you can
preserve things especially if it's a bog
because of a low ph so we find a ton of
dna just in the environment intact
now
a lot of times it's highly degraded so
it can be really hard to get information
from it but sometimes it's not so
degraded and this can be in any
environment so in your gut we're going
to find dna that's just exogenous so
just outside just free-floating dna
you're going to find it on your skin
everywhere
the the push is to really have the
capability to measure it and see what we
get from it
and for viruses specifically rna viruses
i think there's a greater importance
because we know for rna viruses that
they can become infectious and be stable
as free nucleic acids you can have rna
in the environment
and if you take it up whether you're a
microbe let's say a fungus
so rna viruses typically are free
floating as rna in the cytoplasm and
they can remain infectious so if they're
in the environment and they get taken up
into the host they can infect the host
so this presents security questions that
we have to think about or whether it's
for crop health human health or whatever
so this is definitely a growing field
and i wanted to really step my foot in
there so i'm bringing this up so all of
you is people going into the field know
while metaomics is the way to go
there's
changes as a community where we're
trying to become more quantitative we're
trying to see all the different
components and tie things together with
process measurements to really
understand what's going on
so i hope that answers everything about
edna i guess the last thing i'll say is
sometimes you'll see it called relic dna
or ancient dna
and these can have different meanings
the relic dna was really generally meant
because it's thought that it's dna that
left an organism and it's hanging around
for a long period of time whether it be
weeks months years
and it's highly degraded so you don't
get a lot of information on it but you
know it's dna
ancient dna is when we're finding dna
that's an environment
that again maybe years
decades and sometimes can be found in
permafrost or just in soil but these
generally all mean the same thing it's
just dna outside
of a biological entity
well that's super fascinating and super
interesting to learn and i hope that
everyone would definitely want to
investigate further into
understanding the real role that these
things play
so that's
another question which i would like to
pose you is
so elia asks that some people say that
the soil microbiome affects tremendously
the food metabolites and have a chain
effect on the food full food cycle so do
you think that it is true and if so how
and also how stable are these
communities from season and climate
changes or do they depend upon the time
of the year the time of the day and so
on so what's your take on that
absolutely i think soil is extremely
important because
while it's not the largest reservoir of
carbon
it's larger than the atmosphere and the
biosphere combined it's huge but we
interact with it the most we change it
the most right so if you think of a soil
it's you can imagine it as a smorgasbord
of just nutrients but when we're growing
crops the crops take out different
amount of nutrients so we're changing
the soil and before we didn't have crop
rotation like we did now so we would
heavily deplete soils and we erode a
sauce we just we don't treat our soils
well we we kick them around we treat
them like dirt
so it causes issues and our nutrition
which we get from it right
the plants are just like us they will
work
and they'll especially have the help of
fungi to really get all their essential
nutrients but you can definitely have
plants lacking in nutrients or just
plant health where they can be more
susceptible to infection
in different environments i think one
thing we're going to see here with
climate change and a growing population
is we're going to see more and more
agricultural and northern latitudes
especially in peatlands i think a lot of
them will be drained or changed for
agriculture
we know that when you introduce a plant
into a new environment it's susceptible
to disease
so this can cause blights food shortages
other issues so these are ways that
it can affect our security indirectly by
not hurting us
but hurting our food
um
so i think understanding viruses in soil
or in plants or in like the phylosphere
it's all interconnected and we need to
have a better understanding our current
thoughts though
our plants are more infected by rna
viruses or single stranded dna viruses
but maybe we just don't know like we're
missing a component so this is part of
what led me to think in my pea lens
where i've been studying double-stranded
dna viruses i wanted to work on methods
to get at single-stranded dna viruses to
really see
you know if this plant material here and
there's more viruses for plants and this
should be single-stranded dna viruses so
this is stuff we're looking into
um and then your last question was
something about climate change about how
stable the communities are
so climate change is one of my favorite
topics to think about and oh it's hard
to stay up to date on the literature
i'll say that
kristen deangelis at university of
massachusetts amherst has a lot of good
research on this she's studying soils
under warming temperatures and stability
of communities
there's a lot of researches at berkeley
as well look at a lot of the face sites
there's the spruce site in minnesota
so
to gather what i think i remember so far
is the communities are stable right you
don't see huge changes but this is also
from us just taking general metagenomes
right
it could be that the community is there
and then this part activates in the
summer and then this part activates in
the winter and then they work together
right
um
so i think we need to know more of who's
actually active when to see who's
interacting
um i've also spent quite a lot of time
studying viruses and microbes with
permafrost law
and we see that if there are digemic
changes to the soil we have changing
communities so in northern sweden where
i've done a ton of research at stored
allen meyer
and an intact permafrost which was the
dominant previously in the bisco fields
in the biscoe area
was this pulsa habitat where it's
shrubby it's kind of bouncy it's like a
tempur-pedic bed um
you have these stable communities but
then once permafrost thaws and you get a
little bit of ground collapse depending
on how much water or ice was in the
permafrost
then you can get this bog like
environment and it's hard to go back
after that because then when you have a
bog
you promote new plant species that come
in so you get sphagnum moss to grow now
and the sphagnum moss when it comes in
it takes over
it produces this galacto chronic acid
which lowers the ph inhibiting microbial
and other plants from growing
so you only have certain bacteria so in
the pulsa you'll have a diversity of
shrubs and you'll have diversity of
bacteria and archaea when you get into
the bog you now have this increased
abundance and acidobacteria because they
can tolerate the ph so you have boom
it's taking over now so you've just
changed the microbial community and the
viral community because the viruses are
infecting that post
right
then you're also changing the plants
because now you have the the sphagnum
moss that's there
and now it can be somewhat flooded and
it's going to keep that water there well
then you and this is partially thought
then you go into a fully thought habitat
which in this habit
happens to be the sven which is
dominated by this area from which is
this edge so this edge comes in it grows
this large structure
um it can pump some oxygen down but now
we have what's like a wetland ecosystem
where in the pulsa you had
some methane production but you also had
methanol so it's really respiration we
care about in the bog you start to have
hydrogen trophic methanogenesis so you
start getting a various methane coming
out and some respiration as well and
then the fen
you have to switch to this acetoclastic
methanogenesis so a complete change in
the metabolic functions and there's high
abundance of this archaea you have this
wetland with a lot of methane coming out
and a different plant species but then
you also have the diversity of microbes
increase again so it goes from by here
to here to here
so we do see a change with climate
change
but
to give you more specific answers you
would it depend on the field the habitat
and we would have to look into those
papers to assess it for that habitat
right thank you so much for such a
wonderful explanation and such a
detailed answer and i completely agree
that it would
depend upon so many factors as to what
would be
the change for these communities well uh
one thing which was very interesting
from your presentation was the
integration of various techniques that
you brought together
being it metagenomics bioromics the
different aspects of ironics mass
spectrometry and ultimately microscopy
and also the new form of microscopy that
is the nano sims so
what were some of the data integration
challenges that you
might have faced while
dealing with and working with so many
different types of
techniques and the data sets generated
as a result of those techniques
yeah so
there's many different things we could
talk about i think the first thing which
is upsetting
is the amount of specialty
and money that's involved making it not
available for everyone so the with the
first metagenome about 2005 metagenomics
because this next-gen sequencing has
gotten much cheaper
but it's still thousands of dollars i
i've spent nearly a hundred thousand
dollars this past year
on various sequencing costs
and not every lab and not everyone can
afford that you know those cheaper ones
where we'll do amplicon studies with 16s
rrna gene surveys or 18s or its
so these are ways people get around it
so i think a lot of labs are limited
financially and with the expertise and
availability so they do the best they
can
so it's troubling that we have
proposals we have calls and we have
people proposed and the ones getting it
are the ones that have the financial
capability and the means to do it so
they get it and there's not really good
calls to say hey
here's what's needed there's all these
labs i don't have that so these labs can
apply for it so we can bring them up so
there's more labs able to work together
to make the science better versus
selecting a few
and really if you're a newer lab
the way you can
increase your career is you somehow get
involved in a group with one of these
other labs and then it shoots your
career up because you have all this
financial availability and expertise so
for some of the smaller labs
you're it's not it's not possible and so
this is upsetting that we're limiting
who can do what so the things you saw in
my work a meta genome okay a lot of
people can do that now a lot of times
they'll have it paired with amplicon
studies that's good you can do some key
pcr that's great too but then to do a
meta genome and a meditation dome this
is actually quite challenging especially
if you have to know the expertise on
getting this from soil so we're losing
some labs here now and we're losing the
financial capability
and then if you want to add
metaproteomics and metabolomics to
really see it from the beginning to the
end
it's more expensive and i want to
highlight how important that is for
everyone a metagenome tells you the
potential
and you can get a catalog so metagenome
is the base and you need it the
metatranscriptome is going to tell you
the expression of what's happening or if
it's for viruses it can actually detect
viruses but you need the metagenome and
it's not for certain we have a lot of
microbes that will produce mrna like
chump change
to try to get ahead of other microbes it
doesn't mean they're actually doing that
then you have the metaproteome where
they're making the protein and generally
we believe
the microbe is doing this because
proteins are expensive you have these
amino acids you're changing you're
chaining together this is going to be
expensive if it doesn't happen
but we don't know 100 that it is going
to happen or really what comes in
because a protein can function many ways
so then you have the meta metabolome or
metabolomix we actually can look at
these secondary these substrates after
the interaction and really see ah here
is the potential here's how they're
working on it here's actually what came
out of it that gives us the whole
picture it's really hard for labs to do
all this not just financially but if you
think about the amount of time as you
know bioinformatics is a bottleneck not
a lot of people know about it not a lot
of people have access to it it can be
expensive it can be hard to request
hours it is challenging to get your
mindset thinking about that and that
what makes it more difficult is we're
training scientists either in bench or
wet lab as i call it or in
bioinformatics so you become an
expertise in one and not the other
i have challenged myself which may have
not been the best thing but i've
thoroughly enjoyed it to have the whole
picture to be the jack of all trades i
made sure i was in the field sampling so
i could see that environment make the
connection and know the limitations of
my work i was in the wet lab optimizing
the methods getting the dna looking at
knowing the limitations of my work i
then took the time to process it on the
computer because of this
it takes so long to publish and you can
get scooped or
you're already in the dark there are
probably people watching this going oh
man i have a metagenome i thought i was
the best and now i found out it's not
enough i have to have all the stuff i
should give up no don't give up right
it's keep pushing on it i'm showing you
where the fields going to make sure that
we're trying to connect the whole
picture and this can be alleviated by
trying to work with other scientists and
their expertise and then that brings me
to the final part is the expertise while
if you have the wet lab or you have the
bioinformatics you then have to stay on
top of the tools and using the best best
methods and talking with others and this
can be so challenging
um
and then i guess the last thing i'll end
with is nano sims which is not
necessarily a newer thing
it's not as used and it's more unheard
of just like stable isotope probing not
only because it's expensive
but also for the nano sims it's hard to
learn there's only so many in the world
um
we happen to be a facility that has one
and two the government in the united
states to try to help this is they have
these calls to have the national labs
that have these capabilities like jgi
for sequencing pnl from
metabolomics metabolisms in general mass
spec and then us for isotope
radioisotope and nanosims to work with
universities and other individuals to
offer these services
so i want to say if you're out there and
you're wanting to use these
it's harder if you're not a us citizen
but it's not impossible you got to look
at connecting with labs or universities
that have these capabilities to help
push you to the future
sorry that's a lot
yeah but it's thoroughly very
interesting and very it's an eye opener
to learn
from the experiences that you have been
through and i really can connect with
the statement that you made that
how you have gone through the training
of the different aspects of being a
life science researcher and you have
although it takes a lot of time you have
gained the ex experience and that has
given you an understanding of the
complete picture which is i think very
much essential
well people have been thoroughly
enjoying your talk and i can see that
they are extremely glad that you shared
so many things many people are
agreeing to you although there are a lot
of questions from many of our
participants because it's something
which is completely new
but since we have a time limit and i
know that you are also having a very
busy schedule we have to move forward
with today's session but it would be
great that if you could share some ways
to stay in touch with you or maybe to
read your publications
through which our audience can get to
know your research in much detail maybe
your google scholar page or something so
that we can stay in touch and also learn
from your
publications that has been already
published and also the ones that are
upcoming in the future
i do want to say that i'm happy if you
want to share my email um i might have a
lot of emails from people so it'd be
nice if we could group like questions to
me and i can try to answer them via
email um or if anyone's interested in
opportunities it's harder if you're not
a us citizen i'm sorry about that but
there's other ways you can work with
your government and there's governments
that work with the us as well
for my publications i do want to say i
made it a point from the start that it's
frustrating going through school and
when you try to
research knowledge and then there's a
pay wall that just stops you
and it's frustrating especially
and for the us because a lot of our
work's paid for with taxpayer dollars
but then we try to charge the public to
get it i mean this is a worldwide
problem
so i've made it a point to try to
publish everything open access and i'm
pretty sure all except for maybe one or
two of my publications are open access
so you should be able to access any of
my
data and if you can't reach out to me
because i think yeah there is one maybe
two
that if you reach out to me i'm happy to
share with you
all right thank you so much dr gary for
taking out your time from your schedule
it was an amazing experience for all of
us to listen to you to learn from you
and we all hope that we can again get
you back for some other sessions and
learn even further from you thank you so
much for joining us today
thank you
well so uh i would
move on further with we have another
great presentation coming up and this is
from one of our
student fellowship holder at pine
biotech so
before moving on i would just would like
to tell you that we have been learning
so many interesting things about
metagenomics and it's so fascinating
even to me and i hope to everybody i can
see that in the chat so you can
definitely
stay in touch with find biotech
our
host community and the omixlogic
metagenomics program so this is a mentor
guided asynchronous training program
where you can learn the basics of
metagenomics get introduced to the
concepts
learn about the various techniques that
we were discussing today with dr trible
such as the various sequencing
approaches the mass spec approaches you
can learn about them you can learn about
the various functions of the microbiome
and how they regulate everything in our
body starting from energy generation and
metabolism
and these training programs are designed
in such a way that it can integrate the
hands-on aspect so that you can learn by
doing and this is achieved with the help
of the
ai guided cloud-based server platform of
fine biotic which is known as server t
bioinfo and they have various
components such as ingest data analysis
and metagenomics analysis and
multi-omics analysis including machine
learning so
in terms of the metagenomics course you
would get introduced to how to analyze
the amplicons and with the help of the
data to pipeline which is a very popular
analysis pipeline you would learn how to
get started with metagenomics analysis
and i also saw a few questions regarding
databases where you can find data which
you can analyze publicly available data
so you can also get introduced to the
various databases such as silver green
genes ncbi rdp where you can find data
sets of various meta genomes and
microbial communities
and the whole point of
doing these sort of training programs is
to enable you to get started with your
own research project to define your own
ideas to bring together on the table and
to get started to probably start the
start of something great you can
start working on a project get help by
the mentors and you can take that
project to a conference maybe get some
feedbacks from experts such as dr
tribble and push forward your research
career journey to talk about this aspect
and how the experience completely is we
have de lara with us so if you're
interested in this meta genomics program
i will be sharing the link in the chat
in some time you can also watch a video
of a webinar that we had quite recently
regarding this program to learn the
structure and the expected outcomes
but
here's the deal so dilara dekhan is a
graduate in molecular biology genetics
from the bachelor university in turkey
she has been a research fellow at find
biotech and she has been a metagenomics
enthusiast so she was working with
metagenomics datasets learning about it
and then she moved on to apply it in her
own project she's also an astrobiology
enthusiast especially especially looking
after the health of astronauts so she
analyzed how metagenomics can play a
role
and provide better health care for
astronauts who are
living on the international space
station
so
it's our pleasure to have delara with us
today and
we are all here to learn about
what our project deals with what was her
experience of going through the programs
the training courses at pinebiotics
platform and ultimately being a part of
the research fellowship where she got
the opportunity to work on her own
project so without any further ado i
would welcome dilara to take away the
stage hi dilaura how are you doing
thank you that was a great introduction
um i'm doing well i hope everyone's
doing well too
and so i will
immediately share my screen
i'm not sure if you can see it can you
see it now
not yet
okay it's coming up yeah okay we can say
it now
cool so
basically um as subragi said
i am quite interested in metagenomics
microbiology and um
astronaut health astrobiology all of
those things
and i'll give a short introduction on
how i got interested in these things and
then i'll talk about my project that i
conducted during
my internship at
pine biotech
so
an overall is that my
research was based on the adverse
effects of high let radiation
on the mouse uh gut microbiome and
consequently on the nervous system
causing psychological disorders like
anxiety and depression
so why am i so interested in microbes
and it's because um when you think of
microbes we usually think pathogens but
that's
changing now we don't only think of you
know microbes that make us ill but we
also think of them as a treatment now we
can um help use the these microbes using
metagenomic studies to find
unconventional treatments for diseases
like cancer or atopic dermatitis
and also because it's obviously a core
of astrobiology studies and it's
essential in understanding evolution
because we
were
coexisting for all these years so we
cannot understand our own evolution
without the evolution of microbes
and of course as um dr gary and uh as
this has discussion touched upon it in
climate change and agriculture studies
and finding renewable resources microbes
are invaluable
so i chose this topic specifically astro
health because of the prospects of space
travel and how they advance therefore
the research involving space travel
increases proportionately so among
biology biotech and human research
conducted on the iss the international
space station
are studies on how humans and animals
are affected by space travel
which will be important for us in the
future
so it's a fast-paced and growing field
and my research specifically is on a
space type radiation called ionizing
radiation
and more specifically high led linear
energy transfer radiation high led
radiation can penetrate into
microstructures and has enough energy to
cause chemical change
lead which leads prominently to zelda
and according to the information
collected by the iss research the
effects of radiation exposure on human
health
are currently uncontrolled and will
continue to be so for the foreseeable
future
one promising factor however is that
host microorganism interactions will be
optimized to say the least by around
2028.
so here's my methodology i had three
main stages which was data exploration
statistical analysis
and then drawing conclusions in the data
exploration stage i found my data set
which was on mousecut microbiota from
ncbi and then using the
tbi info platform i use the data two
pipeline and the phyllo seek pipeline on
the data set that i had which was 16 as
amplicons
um to find uh paths that could lead me
um further into
understanding the data so then i
conducted anova and t test to find if
the
observations i made during the pilocy
stage were correct and then finally i
tried to connect these results to
palpable
therapy ideas potential therapy ideas
so my data set was a total of 80 samples
and it was divided into two categories
one was based on radiation
going from zero point one point two five
and one gy radiation and the samples
were collected ten days post radiation
and thirty days cost radiation
and here is one of the outputs that i
got from the phyloseq pipeline which is
nmds non-metric multi-dimensional
um
scaling which helps us observe the whole
data set and
find
relative
connections between them or separations
and in this one we can see the relative
separation between the families of
bacteria found in those samples
collected from the gut microbiota
and here i observed from this angle that
10 days post radiation is more grouped
than 30 days post radiation
and then another up
output of the final seek pipeline was
the shannon index graph
and
the shannon index is a value used for
measuring the richness and evenness of
species in different samples
so from my comparison here i found that
between
the four different
radiation doses the shannon index
decreases with exposure to radiation at
lower doses than at higher doses and i
also during my research found out that
this is due to the properties of high
led radiation
and this is an excellent example that
summarizes my entire findings during the
pre the x data exploration stage
and from here we can see from the
phylogenetic tree um that the otus that
are significant
that change significantly from the
control group which was zero gy
and we can see that 0.1 um gy had lower
abundances compared to zero we can also
see that otu four and five have a common
ancestor in recent times
so this is one of the very most useful
graphs that came out of the file seek
pipeline that helped me
make um
analytical observations and then i
decided to use statistical analysis
which was the anova and t test
to make sure that my observations were
correct
and you can see from the simplified heat
map
that otu 3 4 5 and 8 um were the
significantly decreased ones and i also
came to the conclusion that 0.1 gui
collected at 10 days post radiation was
a significant group and i also found out
that there was a connection between the
samples connected
collected at 10 days post radiation and
the
radiation dosages so there was no
relation between those two categories
and the most significantly decreased
ones were the ones that were exposed to
0.1 gy radiation
so from this uh i also
came to the conclusion that the
abundances for
lactobacillus life the bacterium and
aerosol pelotrica bacteria
were the most significantly decreased
abundances
the ones i'll be focusing on however is
lactobacillus and bifidobacterium since
they contributed to the imbalance in the
nervous system through protein coding
genes that they have and these protein
coinding genes correspond to gaba
and gaba is a gamma amino butyric acid
which is the chief inhibitory
neurotransmitter in the central nervous
system and it is generated by
bifidobacterium and lactobacillus too
therefore a decrease in these species of
bacteria can cause or enhance disorders
like depression and anxiety which are
very common in astronauts
and here you can see that there are two
pathways the gs and the gls through
which these bacteria affect gaba
so from all of this we can conclude by
saying that lower doses of high elite
radiation have a greater effect on otu
abundance in this case it is 0.1 gi
and we can also surmise that
the acclimatization period is between 10
and 30 days since the samples collected
30 days post radiation did not pass the
significance threshold but we also have
to keep in mind that these mice were not
exposed to radiation
in the long term the way astronauts are
and some of my limitations were of
course
um the difficulty of the taxonomic
profiling since 16s regions are quite
similar
for bacteria in the same genus
and then there's also the technicalities
of optimization and the limited sample
size was another issue but all in all
this is a good precursor study from
microbiota studies in space and further
research should include
synergistic effect of radiation and
microgravity together
and of course um
in this whole stage i couldn't i don't
know because i didn't have a
bioinformatics background i don't know
how i could have achieved this if i
hadn't come across pine biotech and the
t bio info platform because that greatly
helped me along with the advisors like
dr mohit elia and dr harpreet who helped
me throughout my research
so
here are my references and
thank you for listening to me i hope
this was enjoyable
thank you so much dilara
that was an amazing presentation
and it's also it's a pleasure to listen
to you every time well there would be
one question that
we have in the chat and it would be
great if you could address it in brief
for example first of all what was the
duration of the study the samples that
were exposed to the radiation what was
the duration
and
finally if you could explain the results
again
uh and their fighters look like the
final genetics that you got
and what those families usually you can
conclude from those families that you
could find
yeah so um basically the duration
uh was not specifically mentioned in the
article that i chose the samples from
but it mentioned that it was uh during
one day so it wasn't as long term as
astronauts do and we have to consider in
animal studies of course like
um
you know we can use mice musculus as a
sample animal model but we cannot expose
it to as much radiation as humans
do are exposed to in states also
and i guess this was the phylogenetic
one that you would like me to explain so
basically
when you run your samples through the
phyllo seeking data two pipeline
uh they go through all the usual stages
like normalization and you know your
samples are cleaned etc
uh and then this is the output that you
get and from this you can here um
understand
that um
one point two five and zero i don't know
if you if i enlarge it if you can see it
more clearly
um
but from this you can tell the
abundances of o2s and o2s are
operational taxonomic units when you
render the other two pipeline and the
phylum seek pipeline together you don't
um
exactly get
all of the
genus and species names of the bacteria
that are
in the sample first of all because um
there are a lot of dna samples that are
not titled that are not named
and then they're also the fact that um
when you run these these dna samples are
very volatile and they break a lot so
you know estimations have to be made and
um the system basically when you're in
the pipeline will align the dna samples
that are present in
these microbiota eco samples as much as
possible
and then it will not give it a name
uh it will not first it won't run it
through the
databases and say like this is like the
best routes or this bifidobacterium the
first thing you get is operational
taxonomic unit
which is similar to saying this is one
type of bacteria but it's not
specifically named so that's what otu
means here that's what the otus are
and then you what you get is um these
correspondences you know otu4 is and
otu5 is by for the bacterium genus and
etc and the you don't usually get down
to um the species name if you don't
optimize it too much
because um
of the limitations as i said of the you
know the numerous types of bacteria that
are still not sampled named or sampled
you know they're not in the database of
these dna samples so they're usually
left down to the genus name so that's
why um how that's how i made the
correlation between otu and
uh the bifidobacterium and lactobacillus
basically i took out what was in the
um final seek pipeline what this gave me
as a correspondence you know it gave me
bifidobacterium and lactobacillus and
then i ran it again
on the jgi pipe you know database and i
found the genus uh and species name
together which are these ones
that's great and
yeah yeah and is there a correlation
between the
abundances that you found and the
neurological activity with gaba that you
mentioned
yeah so basically um because i was using
samples that were
previously um
you know collected by other researchers
this was like a totally bioinformatic
study i couldn't exactly go back and
analyze the
behavior of mice so i couldn't
conclusively say
that the the decrees affects the nervous
system i can't say that because i don't
i didn't work with those mice basically
but what i can do is run through again
the jgi pipeline and find that these
um bacteria
have protein coding genes for sure that
affect the human nervous system they um
basically through
the um central nervous system
and through the um
enterodenderitic nerve which is a nerve
that goes through your gut
and collects these chemicals and it
affects your central nervous system in
return
so in theoretically i can say that a
decrease in the abundances
will cause anxiety and depression
because gaba
conclusively decreases so that's what i
theorize basically
right that's clear for us now thank you
so much dilara for your presentation it
was amazing to go through your project
and to learn about the aspect where you
can apply metagenomics in such a newly
discovered field of science which is up
and coming and this is something really
exciting well we also have many
questions in the chat so you can take
some time to maybe uh address them in
the chat or maybe share some
relevant
resources which people can go through
and it's amazing to see such interest in
the audience today because that's the
entire goal of organizing these webinars
where we can infuse the interest and
excitement that we share as a community
and that's really amazing to see so
it's good to have so many different
sorts of questions and to have that
enthusiasm because that is something
which we
always are on the lookout to address as
a part of the various training programs
running all across the globe as a part
of pine biotech
so before we end today's amazing session
which has been such a great experience
for all of us together i would like to
bring to the notice of your audience
that about some of our great
collaborations and partners with
homepoint biotech has started to bring
to you some exciting opportunities so
first of all beginning with the people
in the united states of america pioneer
tech has recently partnered with nippy
which stands for national association of
idea principal investigators
which exists in 23 countries 23 states
in the united states of america and
puerto rico
and the people who are residing in these
states would get an opportunity to
get access to the various training
programs and the courses that find
biotech has designed
and you also get to work on the various
project-based training programs that we
have with mentor support so that's
something which you should definitely
look forward to and
keep an eye on
find patrick's home ground is louisiana
and therefore the partnership and the
help that we have got
throughout the years from louisiana
state university has been amazing and
our relationship is so great that now we
have
collaborated together to bring
bioinformatics machine learning in
biomedical data science transcriptomics
and various other domains of omics and
bioinformatics courses and education to
the people living in louisiana at a much
privileged manner so if you are from
10 states of louisiana and you know
people and definitely it's for many
other people who reside in any part of
the world can access now that we have
we are offering it online remotely so it
gives you an added benefit
there has been recently a great
collaboration with our international
partners namely amity university the
uttar pradesh campus
and there was an amino mou signing which
has led to the massive collaboration
between amit university and pine biotic
as a part of this partnership and
collaboration we can now bring industry
academic internships for people
in india students of any level
especially if you belong to the amity
university network and alumni group you
can get this access to the various
industry academic internships and
opportunities presented to you by paying
biotech but that's not the end
if you belong to any part of the entire
asian continent this is good news for
you because spine biotech has also
partnered with faba that is a federation
of asian biotechnology association they
are a leader in various bioinformatics
and biotechnological industries in the
entire asian subcontinent
as a result of this partnership pine
biotech can now
give you a greater amount of
opportunities to get training advanced
internships
projects and even career opportunities
if you are part of our
community and courses so it's definitely
a good option to stay connected with
fanbiotech and to be a part of all our
upcoming
workshops and opportunities so just like
we are having the omixlogic metagenomics
training program running in the month of
january we are also going to launch a
very exciting training program which is
known as omixlogic genomics that really
goes deep into the domain of analyzing
and interpreting genomic data
giving you the concepts of
interpreting ngs data sets and
leveraging
programming languages such as python and
r to get the best out of your data set
and to understand the biological
reasoning behind the data sets that are
produced
now i would also like to inform you
about some exciting workshops coming up
very very quickly so this is on 11th and
the 12th of january this is a part of
the omixlogic genomics program and this
workshop will introduce you to the
concepts of genomics and its application
in biomedical data science we will also
touch upon genomics and interest data
analysis something which i was telling
you right just now
pre-processing data analysis genomics in
r and python
there will be a guest lecture by dr
sanjeev kumar who is the founding
director of bio course life sciences and
alumni of indian institute of science
bangalore who is an industry expert
in programming well biomix machine
learning deep learning and also research
mentor and he will be sharing his
insights on single cell genomics and
high throughput spatial genomics
there will be
many other exciting talks on ng single
cell data analysis and
various project examples that students
have done and also you can be a part of
in the future
and we will also touch upon how genomics
can really improve the infrastructure
and quality of agriculture in our world
such as dr trouble was touching upon
the
impact these
microbes can have on our food and to
analyze that and to really increase the
yield of our production definitely we
can we need to leverage genomics and
metagenomics so some that is something
which you can learn by being a part of
this workshop so here's the complete
schedule of the two-day workshop i would
request you to take screenshots of this
particular slide if you're interested in
checking out any of the sessions i would
recommend you attending all the sessions
to get the most out of these
opportunities
and
the best way to keep in touch with us
and to know about any of the upcoming
opportunities and events that we have
here you should definitely stay in touch
with our social media handles i invite
you all to
check out the links in the chat you will
find that we are present in every
platform out there and i also invite you
to
join us in the various groups that we
have on facebook and linkedin because
the members of this group are constantly
communicating with one another you would
find various
students who are at your level and
various experts who are there in who
have the best knowledge of
the art that we are doing so it's really
a great
opportunity for you to interact with
them and to learn about various
opportunities and options so i highly
recommend all of you to check out the
links and join us in this particular
journey now psionics is a recurring
event it's not a once stand event so we
had some great people who shared their
research and insights in the month of
november on bioinformatics and data
science in december we did a really
interesting and exciting session on
study abroad because that was a popular
interest amongst various students who
wanted to learn about various
scholarship opportunities
how
applications need to be made what's the
best design of a cv etc so we
gathered people from all around the
globe who has been through this process
to talk about this thing
now it's the month of january and we are
focused on metagenomics just like an
amazing session that we had today we are
also having other sessions coming up
which i will give you the insights on
really quickly in the month of february
we will have sessions on bioinformatics
and data science that would touch upon
the role of various machine learning
models and various algorithms that you
can leverage in your project and all of
this
leads up to the mega event that we have
in the month of march that's the omex
logic research symposium our conference
which will be held remotely so that
everyone can join in and there will be
some great talks by some great
scientists from all over the world both
from academic and industry and there
will be also an opportunity for students
to showcase their research as a part of
the poster presentation session so
check out our social media handles again
that's the reason i shared them with you
very soon we will be rolling out the
various call for abstracts where you can
submit your research project abstracts
and participate in the poster
presentation competition so do
keep an eye on that call for abstracts
for you guys
so
talking about the upcoming sessions the
next psionic sessions when they will
meet again is on the 21st of january
it's a friday again and the time is 3 pm
cst 9 pm gmt
and this session will be
done by dr christopher m taylor who is
associate professor at the department of
microbiology immunology and parasitology
at the louisiana state university health
sciences center and he will be talking
about metagenomics and microbial
communities he has a rich experience of
training students in metagenomics and
making them ready for
analyzing any metagenomics data so i'm
looking forward to seeing all of you on
the 21st of january for this exciting
session and i hope that
you can make the best
out of all of these webinars that we
organize
in the month of february as i said we
will be having dr abhishek and gupta who
is an assistant professor at the center
for computational biology and
bioinformatics at the amit uni institute
of biotechnology in amit university of
pradesh and he will be talking about
network construction and inference as an
elegant approach to understand disease
pathogenesis which is a very trending
topic in the times of kobit 19 and other
pandemics
so the date is 4th of february 2022 and
the time is 5 pm ist that is indian
standard time
so
again keep an eye on our social media
handles we will be rolling out all these
notices again there along with the links
so finally it's a request to all of you
at the end of this brilliant session to
feel this feedback form because that is
essential for us to
make sure that we deliver the best
for you people and
it's a request to please go and fill out
this form it won't take more than two
minutes but it will help us provide you
the best experience in the future
so i hope that you had an amazing
session today because definitely i had
a lot of fun learning about so many
amazing topics today and it's just the
beginning 2022 will have
many exciting sessions which will be
a very
impactful addition in our lives as
student researchers
so finally i would end on the note
uh with this note that join our ciamex
group we are there on various social
media channels such as we have these
groups on whatsapp telegram and slack
you can check out our website as well
and you can scan these qr code to be
redirected to the
website and you can get all the
information out there
so on that note
it's time to bid all of you goodbye it
was a lovely experience to talk to all
of you and to see this right interest
and i hope that we can only grow from
this particular point in the future
thank you everyone for joining us today
and
wish you all the best with your future
may 2022 be extremely productive and
fruitful and happy for all of you thank
you so much everyone for joining and see
you soon